you guys know that any opportunity to uh
explain a uh an economics concept or a
behavioral economics concept i i welcome
those opportunities on the show and
today i have that opportunity thanks to
an anti-vaccine leader who has repented
an anti-vaccine leader who was
completely committed to their
anti-vaccine activism but has now
changed their mind and admits
that the anti-vaxxers have deaths on
their consciences if not on their hands
this is a very interesting story and
there's a lot to say about it as
newsweek reports
anti-vaccine speaker pasquale bacco
repents after one of his fans has died
of covid
unvaccinated and we'll talk a little bit
about when it becomes personal
an italian anti-vaccine speaker has
expressed remorse about his actions
after he discovered that a follower of
his who died of covid had videos on his
cell phone of speeches that he made
pasquale bacco is a doctor
who was a prominent anti-vaxx activist
in italy taking part in numerous rallies
and events
but now bacco who has more than 7 000
followers on facebook said he was a
believer in the effectiveness of
vaccines
when asked by the interviewer what
changed his mind bako talked about an
incident in which he saw a 29 year old
man die of covet quote he had on his
mobile phone
the videos of my rallies at the
demonstrations of the unvaccinated the
family told me he was a fan of mine they
didn't tell me with anger on the
contrary and this hurt me even more i
feel like that death was my fault
and the thing still bothers me today for
it was not a creed when i saw the
reality of my own eyes with my own eyes
i realized that i was wrong
asked whether he felt guilty about his
actions bacco said i think that those of
us who went up on those stages
have deaths on our conscience
all of us anti-vaccine activists have
been great cowards we went to the
squares and when we spoke we knew that
people wanted to hear shocking things so
you provoke more and more
we were really big bastards i don't hide
it that's the truth for this i have
asked for forgiveness from everyone but
that forgiveness is useful he spoke at
around 300 anti-vax protests and was the
only young doctor with experience among
the speakers and he now recognizes the
destructive power of being a doctor
at these events he said quote what i
said was pure gold for people who were
afraid and looking for certainty you
don't realize you are losing your
rationality you lose your mind while
being a rational person at that moment a
dangerous process takes place that
anti-vaxx is a faith and you become a
god you enter absolute madness the
anti-vaxxers are people who are afraid
and find security in you
so many important things here number one
for years i have been talking about this
phenomenon
wherein
part of what makes conspiracy theories
and conspiratorial thinking attractive
is that it provides certainty in an
uncertain world and that applies here
and i'll explain it in very clear terms
well let me give an analogy first and
then i'll explain what what this is
why is it that to some people it's
appealing when there is a horrible mass
shooting that kills 20 kids i won't even
say the name of it because then the
video will get demonetized or limited
there's a mass shooting and 20 kids die
and some people come out and they say
it was a false flag planned event
with crisis actors
meant
to
create fear
to justify taking people's guns why why
do they say that because the truth is
really scary the truth is uncertain
the truth is
kids are mostly safe in school
but
sometimes
seemingly randomly you might say well
we're in nebraska so it won't happen
here or we're in connecticut it won't
happen here
randomly these horrible things happen
and your kid is killed
and that uncertainty is really difficult
for many people to accept and so it's
more in a sense comforting to believe
there's no randomness here this was a
planned event now it ignores that the
event could be planned at your kid's
school or someone else's school but it
gives you a sense that there's not this
random
unpredictable nature to the world
similarly it's really stressful to them
to believe well there's a virus and most
people are okay but a bunch of people
die and sometimes who dies is
unpredictable could it be me or maybe
not and there's this vaccine which it's
mostly effective at preventing people
from dying but it's a bell curve
distribution and every once in a while
there will be people who are fully
vaccinated and they die so it's simpler
to believe
the vaccines just don't work
they're evil tools they are meant to
control people or microchipper
they would rather that it's all planned
it's all planned rather than the vaccine
probably will protect you but it might
not and the virus probably won't kill
you but it might and it could be your
parent or child or would
and that is exactly what pasquale bacco
is picking up on here when he says the
certainty
of the anti-vaxx stuff particularly
hearing it from a doctor is so important
now do we like forgive this guy it
doesn't even really matter i mean it's
not it's not about forgiving or whatever
the case is one other thing that's at pr
at pray here at play rather is don't
fall prey to the sunk cost fallacy
you're always better off coming around
and turning back to sanity and a lot of
people like this guy because they feel
like i'm really committed to this
anti-vac stuff
i'm too far gone i'm not turning around
you can always come back and the sunk
cost fallacy a couple of examples are
you buy a ticket to a movie
to two hour movie and after an hour and
15 minutes you're like this is the worst
movie i've ever seen but i already paid
so i might as well stay
if you could better use those last 45
minutes to do something more enjoyable
than watch the crappy movie you've paid
for the ticket either way you shouldn't
stay because you've already sunk a cost
into that movie you get out and you
enjoy the last 45 minutes doing
something else that's the sunk cost
fallacy another one is you know you go
to a casino
and you lose 80 percent of your money
and you stop having fun but you figure
well i lost 80 of the money i might as
well keep playing now you don't have to
keep playing and lose all of it just
walk away and go do something that's
more fun so that's the sunk cost fallacy
good for pasquale here
not falling forward and saying as far
gone as i am i'm gonna turn around and
that's exactly what he did and you know
i i i'm not even saying he should be
forgiven or not but very interesting
commentary from this guy
one of our sponsors is kamikoto who
creates elegant high-end japanese steel
kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan
i'm a huge fan of japanese kitchen
knives i've owned a bunch of different
sets none as nice as my kamikoto knives
made with real japanese steel
every knife comes in a beautiful heavy
duty ash wood box and a lifetime
guarantee you can get them in several
different sets and combinations kamikoto
makes it really easy to figure out which
one is best for you you can also pick up
one of kamikoto's sharpening wet stones
which are designed especially for
kamikodo knives i've had an excellent
experience using kamikodo knives in my
kitchen at home it just feels
comfortable in your hand the mechanics
of slicing with high quality japanese
knives like these feel really really
nice and right now kamikoto is having a
huge valentine's day sale
you get 50 off on top of their other
offers when you go to
kamikodo.com pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below